well they were so fed up uh like i was
so
you know i'm a small business guy who uh
previous governor
martin o'malley had raised taxes 43
times in a row
uh and it had crushed our economy we had
lost 10 000
businesses and a 100 000 jobs and people
were fleeing the state
in all directions it was frustrating to
a lot of people and it was to me as a
small business owner and it was didn't
matter what your party affiliation was
people were were leaving and a gallup
poll came out that said 47 percent of
all marylanders wanted to leave the
state
and that was kind of the straw that
broke the camel's back for me
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report as always guys don't forget to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
click that notification bell
and joining me today is the 62nd
governor of the great state of maryland
and the author of still standing
surviving cancer riots a global pandemic
and the toxic politics that divide
america
governor larry hogan welcome to the
reuben report
well thank you dave it's really great to
be with you thanks for having me
my pleasure that is quite a title of a
book i mean you have got
that is a your title is a book unto
itself
uh right you made it all the way through
so i was impressed with that so thank
you
thank you i i've become a master of the
teleprompter but actually i thought that
that would be an interesting place to
start because uh the book is coming out
this week
and you actually made a whole bunch of
additions
to the book because of what's happening
right now so i thought that might be
the right spot for us to kick off here
yeah dave it was already
kind of a long title to begin with
because we were trying to cover a lot of
important
topics you know and i was covering you
know when i i was elected
um kind of overcame i was the biggest
upset in america in 2014 in a very blue
state i was
immediately hit with the dealing with
riots in baltimore and then
life-threatening cancer and you know a
lot of interesting stories to write
about
i really wanted to talk a little bit
it's not a heavy political read but i
wanted to talk a little bit about
you know the divisive politics today and
some of my thoughts on where we ought to
be heading
um and and we put together this book
sort of uh
you know february time frame was when we
were finished with it
and it was going to come out a little
earlier and uh and then the pandemic we
kind of put it on hold and ask the
publisher to hold it
it would only hold it until now and
they asked us if we would add so some
more current
activities because i was dealing with
this crisis and we added about five
chapters on the pandemic and i think it
makes it
kind of more interesting and i tell some
pretty straightforward stories about
what we've been dealing with
but i'm hoping people will find it
interesting yeah so
i want to go into each of the specific
topics that you break down
in the title but let's start with the
pandemic stuff
because as you just mentioned you are a
republican governor of a largely blue
state
if i'm not mistaken only two republican
governors have ever been re-elected
in in maryland in its entire history um
so maybe we should start there first
what's it like being an outsider
governor
whether it's you know a a red guy in a
blue state or a blue guy in a red state
just what's that like first before
pandemic time and then we'll talk about
that sure
yeah so i i you know i'm a lifelong
small business guy
never never held elective office until i
was elected governor
um our state was has the highest
democratic registration of any state in
america in 2014 i got elected
it was kind of a shock i mean nobody
expected me to i came from nowhere
we weren't even on the radar screen it
was kind of i was the least likely to
succeed i think nobody thought i was
going to be governor
but i pulled together a coalition of
you know all the few republicans we had
in our state along with
a bunch of independents and democrats
and i got elected
and then i'm governing in a state that's
a fairly liberal democratic state with a
legislature that's
70 percent you know democrats
in both chambers every single statewide
elected official
is a democrat i'm only a second
republican 50 years to be elected and
the
second one to be reelected in 242 years
so
it's look i think one of the things i've
learned in a situation
like that is that you've got to figure
out a way
to work with people on the other side of
the aisle and
it may be different if you're say a
republican in a red state
or you're a democrat in a blue state you
don't have to develop those
relationships and you don't have to
maybe compromise or find a way to reach
that middle ground
you know where you can all work together
so maybe out of necessity to get things
done
i had to be more pragmatic and figure
out
how do you how do you reach common sense
solutions and actually fix some problems
and
it turns out that turn that's what a lot
of people seem to want
because a lot of democrats and
republicans and independents seem to
like it and they
they reelected me and you know we seem
to be making some progress
are you telling me that people vote you
guys in to fix
problems is that is that what it's all
about i know i know
dave it sounds like a strange concept in
politics today because we don't see a
lot of that but i really do think it's
what a lot of people want i mean
you know we can talk about the
politics on the right and the left i
think most people regardless of where
they fall
on the spectrum they really do want uh
their
the people they elect to to office
regardless of which side of the aisle
they come from they just want people to
get to work and get things done and uh
and i think they're frustrated with the
political process and the fact that
they see a lot of divisiveness and
dysfunction they don't think people
people are getting the
job done you mentioned that you were a
small businessman before going into
politics
my sense is that the future of politics
probably on either side although i think
probably more on the republican side
is that the day of the long-term
politician the guy who comes up through
the system
is over and that the future will be
people who built their own businesses
who
innovated maybe we're in the tech world
that those will be the future
politicians
do you think that gave you unique uh a
unique way of looking at the world that
has been has been relevant for governing
i you know well first of all i agree
with you
i i think that is what we're going to
see it's what we should see
i mean i've for a long time uh sort of
been arguing against
career politicians who spend their
entire you know
professional lives in elective office
and it's i think it's what the founding
fathers originally had in mind you know
about
people just leaving whatever it was they
normally did and going in and
serving for a while in public service i
actually you know i'm the chair of the
national governors association
and active in the republican governors
association a lot of my colleagues
have similar uh profiles and backgrounds
not all of them
many of them are not lifelong
politicians
many of them have business backgrounds
and i think it may be a
sort of a new phenomenon but i'm not
alone in that regard and i think
maybe in the governor's races you may
send somebody off to washington
that's you know been a politician but in
when you're deciding
who the ceo or the chief executive is
going to be to run your state
uh you know they want to pick somebody
that's kind of competent and able to run
things and get things done and uh so you
see a lot of business backgrounds in the
folks that are running the states
yeah i think it's it's helped me a lot i
mean i you know i
i knew a little bit about government and
i knew some stuff about politics
but the business background you know my
whole career was about trying to
you know bring people together to get
things done and it turns out
that's actually a valuable thing to have
in government too
you know you don't say accomplishments
yeah
i mean strange nobody ever figured that
out before
do you find maryland to be a
particularly unique case these days
because of the proximity to washington
d.c where so many of the
the long-time bureaucrats and the people
that have just been in the system
forever
a ton of them live in maryland obviously
and that maybe filters a little bit of
what the political life is like there
maybe to a certain extent i mean what
big one of our largest population
centers is in metropolitan
washington but we're a pretty diverse
state you know we've got the washington
metropolitan area the baltimore
metropolitan area
but we've got you know some some pretty
dense areas we've got
you know but it's we've got suburban
areas very rural areas of our state
about 70 percent of our state
is rural um and so we're kind of a
microcosm i mean we're a we're
american miniature we have a little bit
of the same things that everybody has we
have probably a higher percentage of
federal government employees so we
actually have more people that are in
the private sector that maybe have
some kind of government contracting
affiliation but um
it may change we're made a little bit
more liberal and a little bit more
democratic leaning as a result of that
um it made it more challenging for me to
get elected but
you know we've been able to win over
some of those folks which is common
sense
what was going on there before you were
elected that uh a blue state would say
oh
yeah let's uh let's let this guy in
who's not a career politician who's
cobbling together this kind of strange
coalition
well they were uh so fed up uh like i
was so
you know i'm a small business guy who
would previous governor
martin o'malley had raised taxes 43
times in a row
and it had crushed our economy we had
lost 10 000
businesses and a 100 000 jobs and people
were fleeing the state
in all directions and was frustrating to
a lot of people and it was to me as a
small business owner and it was didn't
matter what your party affiliation was
people were were leaving and a gallup
poll came out that said 47 percent of
all marylanders wanted to leave the
state
and that was kind of the straw that
broke the camel's back for me
um we were 49th out of 50 states in
economic performance
yeah so i um i i was frustrated enough
to
do something crazy like say i've had
enough i'm going to run for governor
and it was the point where democrats
said you know i'm a lifelong democrat
i've never considered voting for a
republican in my life
but this guy's starting to make sense
and i focused on the economic issues and
talked about
you know we were going to cut taxes and
regulations and focus on growing our
private sector and trying to put more
people back to work and it's exactly
what we did we had the biggest economic
turnaround in america
we we we had more businesses open and
put more people to work than ever before
in the history of the state and
we got things done even with our
democratic legislature
do you think bottom line when you get
rid of all the other issues that you're
dealing with all day
that if you as a governor can keep the
economy chugging and keep people at work
that you've basically done your job
well we you know we're wrestling with
all kinds of really
tough issues dave when you're governor
of the state
as i mentioned you know we're dealing
with a you know close to a 50 billion
dollar budget and
you know 60 some thousand employees we
have to provide all these different
services there's so many different
issues but really it is we're dealing
with educating folks and handling
transportation and
you know law enforcement all these
multitude of things
but the focus that brought everybody
together in our state that they could
agree on they could argue
about various you know different issues
but the one thing they all agreed on was
the pocketbook issues and that's how i
put together i put a group together
called change maryland it was a
nonpartisan citizen organization
and we had just as many democrats and
independents as republicans
and they were just saying let's focus on
these issues
let's not argue about all these other
things right now let's just focus on
these and
we brought together a coalition it
turned out to be a winning coalition and
and uh you know people say how did you
get you know suburban women and how do
you get minorities and how do you get
democrats and
independents to vote for a republican uh
but i think it's one of the things that
republican parties gonna have to think
about how do we reach out to
a wider group of people in order to win
elections in the future and
so we can be in in the position of
making decisions
yeah so i want to get more to that and
the sort of pure political side in a
minute but
let's talk about what's what i didn't
mean to get too political on you dave
a governor getting political i can't
believe it uh yeah let's not do that
anymore
yeah yeah let's let's talk about what's
going on now though because
uh you know there's been i think the
major conversation really
um at a high level is sort of what the
federal government is supposed to do
related to coronavirus and what the
state governments are supposed to do
i suspect i generally know your thoughts
on this but but what do you think
your job as a governor is right now and
what is not your job what is the job of
the federal government
that's a great question look i i think
the governors are on the front lines of
this crisis and
and we ought to be we're we are out
there we're closest to the people's
problems we're working together with our
our local governments and we're trying
to really address these issues that are
on the ground in our individual states
and
each of our states are different we're
going after you know
the different uh situations on the
ground in our states but there was there
was a major there were certain big
things that only the federal government
could do well
so you know early on in this crisis
the federal government could have taken
more of a role in an overall
testing strategy they did you know they
were a little bit i think behind the
eight ball
on um in the early stages and i talked
about this in my book a little bit in
march and april
when they weren't taking it as seriously
i mean there were people in the
administration who were
i think the president downplayed it a
little more than he should have
and they didn't develop a lot of
national strategies
we had 50 individual state strategies
i'm not saying
states shouldn't have had the authority
and independence to be able to make
their own decisions but
certain things like we shouldn't have 50
states competing with one another
in a constrained market for desperately
needed supplies competing with the
federal government and trying to
you know acquire things all over the
world so on testing and contact tracing
and some of the major issues that the
power of the federal government could
really have helped
with the pandemic and in some respects
they're getting better
but certain things the federal
government can just do better
can you talk a little bit about how you
specifically make decisions when it
comes to lockdown or the rest of it
because as you know i'm here in los
angeles california
we've had rolling lockdowns then they
kicked in again last week i was actually
out to lunch for the first time
in weeks and as i was having lunch we
got the the notification on my phone
that said the restaurants
are closing in two hours now
everything's closed again
and i've been very critical of gavin
newsom our governor here
not necessarily because of what he's
doing rather than the messaging
it seems like they just they just give
edicts they never say well we've seen
these numbers change this way
we know this behavior changed this or
that it's just oh now we're locking down
we'll see you in august we'll see in
september and
and that's what i'm sort of more
concerned about can you talk a little
bit about how you message things and how
you actually
come to the decisions yeah it was great
question dave and you hit on a couple of
really good points first of all i agree
that the messaging has been a problem on
be you know i think a lot of the
governors are not
messaging very well and frankly i think
that's where the
president's biggest biggest weaknesses
have been on the messaging side
um i've tried to be just very direct and
up front and provide as much information
as possible because i think most people
whether the the news is good or bad if
you're if you're just
you know frank with them and you supply
the facts in a situation like this when
we're dealing with
you know in some cases life and death
matters and a serious health crisis and
a global pandemic and
economic collapse potentially um people
want to know
the facts and they want to know why
you're making decisions so you know
i think i'm not the only one doing it
but their number the governors who have
been more direct and open and
transparent i think i've been the most
successful
on the decision-making process i just
tried to get
you know we had to make decisions really
quickly in this thing because
it wasn't like we have deliberations
with our legislature and let's talk
about it and form a committee
you know this was happening really fast
at the beginning as we were spiking we
were seeing things happening in italy
and new york and
people dying and bodies stacked up and
overflowing hospitals and
we were hearing these things about two
million potential deaths and
so we were it was speed time it was of
the essence to make some decisions
um you had to make the right decisions
quickly you couldn't hesitate
but i wanted to get the best advice i
could from the smartest people
we put together a task force of really
smart doctors and scientists and
business people
and and i just tried to get the best
input listen to everyone and then
make decisions without hesitating and
then communicate it really well to the
people about this is what we're doing
and here's why
and here's how it's going to help and so
we took very aggressive and early
actions
did things that i never would have
imagined ever doing but it helped us
flatten the curve i mean our numbers are
really good our economy is really good
we took early and aggressive action we
had a safe and effective reopening
and uh you know we're now you know way
down from our peak that happened about
more than 90 days ago
we've opened up 98 of our economy and
our unemployment at eight percent is
staggering but it's it's you know some
states are two and a half times worse
better than the rest of the country um
and um and our numbers
well you know we we've had a number of
deaths and
we had the same problems other people
had we're in great shape right now
yeah on a personal note as a guy that
didn't want to always get into politics
when you have to make those decisions
about okay we're going to extend the
lockdown we're going to lift the lock
down whatever it may be
what's that like for you because i think
people think people think of politicians
sort of as robots like oh they just make
the choices but
yeah no it was really really hard dave
it's
you know i've been through and i talk
about some of these you know personal
and professional struggles and battles
that i've been through in my book and i
share some of that
you know what it was like and and all
the things that i had to deal with on a
personal level or what
battles i went through as governor or
getting elected governor
this was the hardest thing that i think
i've had to deal with um
something we never imagined dealing with
and it wasn't just you know i went
through a cancer battle where
i was worried about how my family was
going to take it or you know what
what was i was dealing with other cancer
patients but this was
i was worried about six million people
in my state and my decisions were going
to impact
not only their health but i'm a lifelong
small business guy ran for governor with
the sole purpose
of creating jobs and helping small
businesses and decisions i was going to
make were going to impact
it was going to cost people jobs and
hurt their small businesses or people
were going to die
um it was a really hard situation to be
put in
and and frankly the president um left it
up he said it's up to the governors
and we were getting you know um you know
open up
and then you know but you have to shut
down he was given the the administration
was giving us advice you have to do
these things
or we're gonna have two million deaths
and then uh you know messaging the
opposite stuff
the next day so it was we were in tough
situations but i think and everybody
made different decisions but
uh on a personal level i mean it's
there's been very little sleep
for five months and a lot of stress and
you got people that are mad at you
either way no matter what you do
you can't make everybody happy and you
know i just tried to do the very best i
could
based on the information i had and you
know try to do the best thing for
for the people in the state yeah so
let's talk about the other
thing that's going on because there is
another thing going on there's always a
lot of things but there's sort of two
main ones going on at the moment and and
the second one obviously
is i guess the best way you you describe
it
is either the racial unrest or the
protesting or the rioting just the whole
conversation we're having
the the toppling of of monuments now
again you're in maryland
dc's right there awful lot of monuments
awful lot of history is right in your
backyard
um you know you've got you've got
baltimore there which has its own
set of set of problems um so i'm not
even going to ask you a question i'm
just going to
i'm going to just pass all that off to
you take it away yeah
yeah well that was that's we're just
going to let me tee it up and
um what so i i you know you look at the
title of the book it's like
riots you know cancer riots a global
pandemic
i i dealt with this and i talk about
this a lot and there's real parallels to
what's going on right now with the
the riots the the violence the unrest
the protests uh
what however you want to describe
there's a little bit of all of that
going on across america in different
cities
um in 2015 right after i became governor
um we had i had only been governor for
89 days
and we had the worst violence in 47
years break out in our largest city in
baltimore after the death of freddie
gray
and uh you know in the very first few
hours
in baltimore city 400 businesses were
burned and looted and destroyed
127 police and firefighters were injured
and hospitalized
the the city police force was
overwhelmed
and the city was really having you know
no ability to respond
it was it was sort of out of control and
as governor
i declared a state of emergency
sent in 4 000 members of the national
guard and a thousand police officers
into the city
we allowed peaceful protests to go on
for a week but we shut down the violence
we stopped
the burning uh the looting uh and all
the damage that was being done
and um you know i write about this
extent i think i have five chapters on
this in the book
um i walk the streets of baltimore for a
solid week
to listen to people i was hugging people
who lost their businesses
in their homes i was meeting with
community leaders i was
talking to faith-based leaders i was i
was walking the streets where freddie
gray's neighborhood i was
you know i was dealing with the crisis
but also trying to lower the temperature
and i think we found the balance of i
call it you know reagan's peace through
strength we sent enough
people in there to keep the citizens
safe to not allow the violence and
destruction
without further inflaming you know the
the the anger and violence by moving too
aggressively
you know we just you know if you were
protesting in the streets
it was okay if you're throwing rocks and
setting things on fire
we're gonna arrest you and i think the
mistakes that were made in some of the
large cities today by just
letting you know mob rule take over and
and just
not to respond at all is a big mistake
there are obviously
legitimate frustrations in the black
community and i i was very proud of
actually baltimore this
this time as we're seeing things erupt
everywhere it was mostly
very peaceful protests without the
violence and destruct destruction this
time and
and i think our our police state police
the national guard and city police and
baltimore did a really good job and
i think the citizens here did a good job
they were actually pointing out the
handful of
you know violent folks that weren't even
from the city and saying hey
stop this they wanted to just peacefully
express their
their frustrations but it's it's uh
something we've got to get a handle on
and i you know i understand
both sides of the argument but i i talk
about this extensively in the book i
think you've gotta
you know gotta find the way to get this
under control
while addressing some of the concerns
how miserable of it
of a decision is it for you when
something's going down in one of your
cities in this case baltimore
where you have to then bring in the
national guard or something else where
i know it's your preference to let the
mayor hopefully do his or her job and
and make sure that they take care of
business but as we're seeing in a lot of
these states right now i mean we're
really seeing it in portland right now
the the mayor seems either unwilling or
unable to
to do anything and and now we've got
we've got in effect we've got federal
troops
in the streets of portland yeah it's uh
they're making the um
the mayor i think by not taking action
early
i think they they made a mistake and i
it wasn't uh
you know i i had i was very prepared for
that i kind of
saw uh what might be happening our team
that's we stood up the maryland
emergency management agency in
about a week in advance we saw things
potentially bubble up a couple days
earlier
i was ready with an executive order you
know already prepared i've been in
constant contact with the city
it's the first violence that broke out i
was on the phone with the mayor
saying you know this doesn't look like
you have it under control
i took action within a matter of hours
uh to come in
and and back up the beleaguered police
that were
overwhelmed in the city and i think you
know that early and aggressive action
again it's sort of like this pandemic
there's no time to delay and hesitate
and to be too passive
but again we we didn't go in there and
aggressively
you know you know cause you know further
escalation of the problem
we just went in there to keep the
citizens safe and they're very
appreciative of it
um you know the people in baltimore were
like thank you because they were scared
they were really worried about this
violence and the people trying to take
over their city
are you hearing from just regular people
that they're really worried about the
sort of mob rule that seems to be taking
effect
regardless of whether your first statue
stands
the fact that they are just coming down
all over the place
um as opposed to let's you know let's
vote
and make a decision or have you know
some some process related to the law
i mean whether you want them down or not
i think most people agree that
tearing them down is not legal at the
very at the very least
do are regular people bringing that up
to you that the rule of law seems to be
uh up in the air at the moment well to
me
i'm shocked that this is even a debate
really
i mean we had we did have although i was
praising
baltimore this time about the lack of
violence we did have a situation where
uh in little italy we had somebody a
smaller group of folks tore down a
christopher columbus statue
now i'm not here to debate the the
merits of whether christopher columbus
was a great guy or not but there's no
way
that we should encourage you know mobs
to be able to tear down whatever piece
of art or history that they want to
instead of going before the city council
and arguing why they think they maybe
should you know put that in a museum or
to something else
we actually had a city councilman member
in baltimore while they were tearing
down that statue
that tweeted something like you know
maybe they should consider going down
and tearing down another statue that was
built to honor
fallen police officers a memorial that
was put up by the families of i mean
it was just unbelievable that we're
having these kinds of discussions
i i understand the debate about some
some of these statues maybe we really
should take a look at
you know making a decision to remove
them and i think that's a bit that's an
argument and discussion we definitely
should have
um and some of them i understand why
they're they may be offensive to some
folks but you can't just allow mobs to
decide which ones they want to tear down
yeah well we seem to be in this sort of
mob
mob moment i suppose you could call it
um
what are you seeing between the the
tension right now between the
republicans and the democrats
you strike me as what i would say is a
pretty moderate republican
um you can you can either you can assess
that statement however
however you'd like but that's what you
strike me as um what what i'm worried
about is that you know
i don't know how much you know about me
but i was i was a lifelong democrat
lefty progressive
until the last couple i know and i know
and
then you saw the light and here we are
right and here we are but but what i am
worried about is that my
my former side so to speak and i don't
like doing it in sides but
you know there's only so many ways we
can talk about these things that my
former side that it seems like if you
don't go
fully woke if you don't go fully to
where the the bernie aoc
energy is that they're just going to
take you out
and are you seeing that at a state level
too
oh yeah no there's no question about
that and so yeah i look i
i'm a lifelong uh republican i was a
chairman of youth for reagan and i was
in
you know i would say most of my life i
would be considered a conservative
republican and now i guess they call me
a moderate because you know
i i i really try to avoid the extremes
of either party and
i think one of the problems we have
today is that you know
first of all i like to avoid the
divisive angry rhetoric and because i
want to work together to get things done
that makes me a moderate i guess
um i don't think um you know trying to
get things done
and finding compromise you know is the
dirty word or compromise isn't a bad
thing
doing nothing is a bad thing getting
nothing done standing up
i'm gonna stick to my principles but i'm
not gonna accomplish anything um
but you know right now i think the
democratic party is moving too far to
the left
and i think the republican party is now
shrinking their base down to not appeal
to enough people
and there's a growing number of people
that are
either moderate or right of center left
of center who are somewhat frustrated
with the entire
you know political process and they're
like this this is the best we can do
and and and and you know they're not
really
on the extremes of either party you know
i you see polling that says you know
maybe 15 percent
consider themselves very progressive or
very conservative
on each side and everybody else is
somewhere in the middle
and they're saying how do we how do we
fix that the exhausted majority that
goes
why can't we get somebody normal and why
can't we get something done
so how do you fix it how do you fix it
it's hard to fix it but i mean part of
it is
i mean it's a broke it look some people
have given up and they're like we're
never gonna fix the broken politics
you know i would argue that some of that
we've been and i talk about this in my
book
um we i think you can you know
lower the temperature try to avoid the
divisive rhetoric
try to find ways to actually work in a
pragmatic way
but there's also structural things that
we have to do i mean we got to get rid
of gerrymandering
and the way our primary process works
only the the people on the extremes win
the primary there's no competitive races
anywhere in the general elections
typically
and we end up with a uh you know people
in congress that are
you know not ever going to agree on
anything and not not
ever meet in the middle on anything so
um yeah i think there we've got to kind
of
work on how do we how do we elect you
know people that are willing to go down
and work together and get i mean i think
people are frustrated
whether they are on the right or the
left about the fact that nobody can get
anything done
yeah i'm willing to work with anybody
i'm kind of i'm the get to work and get
things done school of politics i don't
care
if you're a democrat or republican if
you'll help me fix the problem
yeah and that's sort of been your
position with trump right because you've
obviously i mean even here you've been
you've been
critical of some of his responses but
then there's some other things that you
think he's done pretty well
yeah no well look i've never been um one
of those people you've never seen me as
one of the guys that's on
constantly criticizing the president for
no reason never done that
never been going after him in a personal
way there's plenty of people on
on tv that'll do that constantly but i'm
also never
i'm not one of those republicans that's
afraid to speak up if i disagree which
you know a lot of them are
i just pretty much like i tell like it
is i mean i
have you know i i respect when i praise
the president when they do something
right and
and i and i agree with him when i think
you know he's he's he's
in the right on something but i always
say if they haven't done something well
i'm gonna
i'm not gonna just sit down and shut up
and then keep it to myself
and there are a lot of republicans who
agree with me what they're afraid to say
does it ever sort of kill you that like
a nice guy like you
that trump was willing to do all the
things that maybe somebody like you
wouldn't have done and when i say
someone like you i mean someone like me
too that there are sort of more moderate
people
that maybe just won't do the things that
it takes
to win at that level it's not even a
judgment it just sort of is that
we're all sort of wired a little
differently we all take the temperature
of the room a little bit differently
you know look i'm i'm willing to uh
stand up and
and fight for the things that i believe
in but i'm not for
divisiveness and dysfunction and i would
argue
that um people like me and and we look
at our record over the past six years
we've been more effective and can get
more things done
i'm not sure and it's not talking about
philosophy now or
we're not agreeing with many of the
president's positions and philosophy
i would agree with on the economy and i
think he's done some things that are
pretty good
but he hasn't gotten a lot done in
congress and some of some of it is that
personality and some of it is i think he
could be more successful
i think sometimes he's his own worst
enemy and he could be more effective
if he tried to do some things a little
differently yeah
so yeah i get it you got to stand up and
fight but sometimes
that's not the skill set that you need
to use to get things done
uh let's talk about the personal side of
the book a little bit uh
you talk about battling cancer so
let's talk about it yeah so um i talked
about the riots you know that that was
you know right after i became governor
and i went through that i'd been through
my first legislative session which is a
90-day session here in annapolis and
i was on my first trade mission uh to
asia
i went to korea china and japan i
noticed a lump in my throat
and i was feeling some aches and pains
and i decided to you know go to a doctor
to check it out
i just wasn't feeling terrible i just
felt a little run down and a few
you know things that i noticed and i had
three doctors
uh you know come in and tell me that i
had very advanced and aggressive cancer
uh from my neck to my groin i had 50
some tumors
and it was a rapidly growing
life-threatening
you know large b-cell non-hodgkin's
lymphoma and they
it was pretty grim news they told me
i've been governor for five months
it was friday of father's day weekend
when i got this news
um and i uh you know i had to go home
and
and you know hit me out of the blue i
had no idea i mean you know
this was going on i don't know how these
things were growing inside of me and i
didn't know i'd been through all that
work
winning the campaign going through all
that you know really working hard you
know
10 12-hour days seven days a week and uh
still working like
energizer bunny uh but i i uh you know
the hardest part was
how am i gonna explain this to my family
i went home and told my my wife and my
three daughters and
who were there for father's day weekend
and then i had to you know explain it to
my
my 80 year old dad who was over for
father's day
and then i went and had to explain it to
the my staff
who had worked so hard and you know just
you know
helping us put the administration
together and then had to tell the six
million people in maryland who just put
their faith
in me um and it was uh it was a
difficult thing i was going through
24-hour day chemotherapy
i went through about a 18-month battle
i was very open and transparent i mean i
uh i shared
everything i was going through and it
was you know it was an incredible
it you know i really i think i have a
different perspective
on life it made me realize the important
things
um and i i got to meet some incredible
people who were going through much
tougher battles than mine and
got to meet their families and it's a
whole other focus for me and
even if i'm not a governor it gives me i
mean i'm going to continue to fight to
help
you know raise awareness and raise money
for these terrible diseases
i mean so many people are touched by
cancer i everywhere i go
because of my experience people know
about it and they'll tell me
share their story about what they went
through or their spouse or
their child or their or one of their
parents or somebody
you know somebody you love has been
through this before and it was it was
pretty incredible
yeah did you think about not coming back
even once
you were on the other side just because
you didn't want to deal with the stress
or anything like that
you know they asked me at my very first
press conference when i announced this
news
and i'll tell you a funny story i i had
to do a biopsy surgery
they had to take a lymph node out from
under my arm and the doctor said you
know
you're going to be fully under
anesthesia we're going to give you some
pretty serious painkillers so you just
got to go home and rest and i said well
i can't
i can't go home and rest i got to go to
a press conference and he says
oh you can't do a press conference you
know you're going to be out of it
and i go well i have to because i'm
going to go in to start my 24-hour chemo
and he goes they're not going to ask you
questions at this press conference are
they going to go yeah
pretty sure they're going to ask me
questions so i stood up there and took
questions
and they were like you know you know are
you going to resign
is the lieutenant governor going to take
over what happens if this and what
happens if that and i was
i was sort of on truth serum because i
had all these drugs in me and
and i just it was you know it sounded
like i was telling my family in my
living room i just told the whole public
exactly what was going on
but i i you know i never thought about
resigning i'm like everybody else that
went through cancer i still had to try
to
you know try to do my job and i was
working from the hospital bed i
you know i was they were feeding me full
of so much drugs and
and uh you know i was doing steroids and
i was up all night so i was actually
working more
from the hospital i was texting all
night and telling people you know get
this done and get that done
well listen i uh i know we're tight on
time here so my final question
since you are in annapolis and i
mentioned right before that i get to
annapolis pretty often
do you know the name of that mexican
joint on main street in annapolis
they've got some of the best margaritas
and tacos
i've ever had and i've been trying to
think of the name the entire time i'm
talking about
i guarantee one of your staff knows well
one of the staff
what's the what's the best place on main
street the mexican joint that little
mexican joint
there's a whole bunch of them they do
street tacos oh it's just great
yeah yeah but i don't know but i'll tell
you what when you come into annapolis
we're going to take you there we're
going to find out and we're going to get
you there you know we're going to get
some margaritas when i see you here in
annapolis
that would be a pleasure well governor
larry hogan thanks for doing this and uh
yeah good luck
dave thank you thank you i enjoyed it
all right and if you guys know someone
who could appreciate a different
viewpoint be sure to share this video by
clicking the share
arrow below thanks again governor if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell